hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
[Music]
I'm just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you Oh Nene where you
going I'm gonna go work out there you go
get on the elliptical do it all right
that was part of our prenuptial
agreement keep it looking good it's
exactly what it is you would never dare
try to get a prenuptial agreement what
are you talking about I'm throwing it
out there right now I'm gonna get a post
married prenups post-nuptial agreement
no I'm gonna get all right you know I
don't even give a [ __ ] you want all this
stuff I don't care it's a [ __ ]
headache son taken up for a sandwich I'm
good I want every color of I thought
sure yeah seriously though I will I will
leave you there's a certain level that
if you out if you drop below I'm walking
he's bald pasty redheaded male pushing
50 yeah okay don't look at me like I
don't have options woman I've been out
to the strip malls I've seen the looks
okay you put me in a strip mall near
that has a dentist and a place where
they do your taxes okay [ __ ] head
just whipping around yeah she can at
least pretend that I'm still kind of
good-looking right all right anyways
what's up everybody how are you how's
your week going is it going bad well
it's almost over at least a bad part of
it is huh how about a moment of silence
how about a [ __ ] moment of silence
for everybody who's sitting in a [ __ ]
place they don't want to be right now
huh
there was your moment and you know what
that's all you deserve why are you still
there
stand up push that plastic wheelchair
away from that [ __ ] I know you ain't
below the well then what do you do right
don't do that you need a plant come up
with a [ __ ] plan my stomachs can be
groundling like crazy I just I just got
off of got out for the plane had a 7:00
a.m. flight came back from New York I
went to the just an amazing memorial
service for Charlie Murphy yesterday and
I got to tell you I'm because you know
it's a private ceremony someone can give
any details but I will tell you this you
know comedians we a lot of us may die
young but I will tell you this we have
great funerals it's [ __ ] on believe
it was unbelievable they New York legend
was sent off by legends it was it was
incredible it was really incredible so
yeah still sad though obviously still
sad but he would have been very happy
I'm going to speak from anything but
like I hope I get sent off that well I
thought man it was uh
yeah it was definitely something else
that's great they'll bring up something
that you're not going to really give any
details of well yeah whatever I just I
just so anyways so everybody hung out
afterwards to like 2:30 in the morning
and I had like a you know 7:00 a.m.
flight and the only waited there's two
ways to handle a 7:00 a.m. flight which
is going to involve like a [ __ ] 4:30
a.m. pickup all right there's only two
ways to do it you either go to bed you
know you drink some hot cocoa at 7:00
p.m. and you figure out how you're going
to get your [ __ ] eight hours whatever
you do what do you people do with your
pills huh is that what you do you sit
[ __ ] indian-style foot of your bed
going home oh whatever is whatever that
meditation [ __ ] is all right which I
have not done and I'll tell you the
ramifications of that here in a minute
either do that or you just stay out
drinking with your friends too like 2:30
in the morning and then you come home
you get about an hour and a half two
hours sleep you stagger to the [ __ ]
Airport without to the cab you go in
there and you just the biggest thing is
not to not off at the gate you got to
stay awake but the lights are on in that
type of [ __ ] and then once you get to
your seat
sit then you're out you're out the -
it's [ __ ] and that's a great way to
do it because then you have to sit there
bored out of your mind on the flight you
know by the way thanks to the person
that sent me that [ __ ] creepy video
of that plane crashing which for some
dumb reason I'm sitting there watching
it about the tail section coming off
this plane these pilots trying to figure
out a [ __ ] way to try to land it
which of course you can at that point I
wasn't surprised that they didn't invert
that's always a fun thing half of sleep
to be watching because you know you have
a sleep bone like wait am i on this
flight or is this a this a should I be
feeling that feeling you know they sent
me this video and I'm not getting on
this plane well you know what I got on
that goddamn plane that went right to
sleep and woke up like you know five
hours later five hours later on a 6-hour
flight is perfect you know they come
over sir would you like anything would
you can you can we do blue okay yeah
what do you got well we got a mush Rob
we got a portobello mushroom sandwich
yeah it sounds gross what else you got
I don't even know what the other thing
was I thought when she said the mushroom
thing with the other thing I thought it
was all the same thing that goes at all
one thing or is that two things she goes
that's two things
and I went I III don't want anything I
got a new thing I don't eat on planes
I'm not [ __ ] doing it I'm not [ __ ]
doing it it's just it's it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] food empty calories into you you
like I'm [ __ ] five miles up from the
surface of the love of the earth you
know the only thing you should be eating
up there is [ __ ] that you should be like
like Pringles potato chips and stuff why
would you eat those and you just sitting
again just becoming a fat [ __ ] so I sort
of been doing this thing this year is
I'm trying to [ __ ] drop some weight
here you know even though my dad I'm not
going to have the fun I'm not having the
[ __ ] dad bought not having that thing
you know this thing when you go to lift
up your arms your shirt comes up and
it's just that [ __ ] pork shoulder
spilling out on the side ain't happening
to me oh speaking of which so uh
you know I packed hastily because I went
to Boston first and then in New York and
so I grabbed a suit and everything in my
shoes so I have them for the memorial
service and I forgot to bring dark socks
all right and also I was working out and
doing the elliptical and all that type
of stuff so I thought it brought enough
boxers and I didn't so I was like [ __ ]
so I landed in New York I get to the
hotel and it's you know we're like in
Midtown and [ __ ] we meaning me and all
my [ __ ] personalities and so I called
me up I tell where I'm I was like [ __ ]
you know the car is coming to get me to
take me over to the service you know I
need some underwear where should I go
cuz this is New York there's no [ __ ]
gaps anywhere they're all like downtown
or way uptown I'm right in the middle I
don't have time and she asked me always
and she goes I know that is like giving
a gay neighborhood she goes around the
corner is up there's among those [ __ ]
stores so go across the store right
Street right and there's like you know
the second you see the mannequins you
know to me you know that it's yet this
is like a it's a gay store it's for gay
men so I don't give a [ __ ] I need
underwear right gay men still wear
underwear so I walk in there and it was
just like Jesus Christ it was like [ __ ]
rings on the [ __ ] wall which by the
way I thought that was the same as like
a like when people get their dick Pierce
which I still don't know where they do
that it's like a navel ring but it's on
your dick so I thought a [ __ ] ring you
know I thought that that was the same
thing but it wasn't it was like a look
like something you use in plumbing
like a gasket evidently you put that
around your dick for some reason then
what you swivel your hips and it's like
oh it's like a hula hoop for your dick
evidently right so I [ __ ] go in the
back and that the underwear it's like
ridiculous it was like all these Fred
Flintstone prints you know what I mean
there was like Ashley's [ __ ] and then I
finally find a pair that was just all
black and on the waistband it said nasty
Pig so I finally just yellow order to do
buying the counter grey you got any like
normal like mainstream underwear
here and he's like define normal our
main street I was like on it doesn't say
nasty Pig on the on the waistband it has
material around the ass and when it does
it doesn't say [ __ ] my hole on the back
you know regular just underwear it's
like hang on he [ __ ] comes over there
and he ended up finding some that we
just were all black you know Greg
Louganis style but they were the only
size they had was small which was
[ __ ] hilarious to me because I was
just like yeah why would you have a
medium this is like gay guys they want
to see that their boyfriends junk
spilling out the side oh you nasty pay
so I had to leave there and the closest
place was [ __ ] t.j.maxx oh my god the
[ __ ] animals
half of it was the way they had the
store like the way they had the store
set up it's just like it was so [ __ ]
up it's like it was like I was in
Manhattan the crown jewel of [ __ ]
cities in the United States right and
the second I walked into [ __ ] TJ Maxx
I mean I might as well been in a [ __ ]
Walmart in the middle of nowhere and I
am talking down to middle America in
there Walmart's I am talking down to it
although I'm not a [ __ ] you know those
Walmart aren't that bad other than on
Black Friday Black Friday is the day you
don't want to [ __ ] and go down there
because that's like white people Bloods
and Crips you know that's our version of
it flannels it [ __ ] in flip-flops
that's that's our Bloods and Crips and
you don't still want to be there on that
date you know when they have one Atari
for $3 way in the back of the store and
everybody's just basically going to
trample people like they're going to the
[ __ ] who concert Cincinnati way back
in the day via I mean other than that
you know it's not it's not that bad a
store you know it's got all kinds of
giant selections I've gone in a bunch of
times I don't know why I brought that up
I sell me what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about this point Oh TJ Matt you can
sample the minimality J max so I go in
there and it's you know typical
Manhattan [ __ ] store where it's like
half the stores downstairs and the other
is on the ground so on the others is
like upstairs you know because they slam
this little [ __ ] store in there and I
finally find some underwears and I'm
like [ __ ] I got stand on this goddamn
like Disneyland level line and like all
right they got 12 [ __ ] registers open
so even though there's like 24 people
you know roughly each one of these
cashiers just knocks out two people and
then it's my turn
all right this shouldn't be this bad and
it was this woman in front of me I don't
know what kind of soap she used but like
I would divorce her I swear to God even
if she made my heart stop I'd be like I
love you I wish nothing for you but this
[ __ ] soap it's a specific soap I've
smelt it before it wasn't she didn't
smell bad she smelled of this soap I
don't know what the [ __ ] it is but it
just I can't be around it but I had to
be although someone's going to cut me
and then they just walked you through
you know the Disneyland thing where you
walk all the way to the right then you
go back to the left you know zigzagging
all the way up and just the [ __ ] that
they had you know the impulse buys and
everybody if they weren't staring at
their [ __ ] phones we're just picking
up these things and the more I saw
people picking up the [ __ ] looking at it
like the angrier I was getting like why
you picking that up you don't need that
we finding the names of these [ __ ]
things okay they had this one thing it
said I would thank you from the bottom
of my heart but for you my heart has no
bottom and it was just framed in this
piece of [ __ ] wood frame and on a white
piece of paper with just regular font
like please don't walk away with the
bathroom key like the same kind of font
you would use it that at the gas station
they wrote that [ __ ] cheesy heartfelt
message and
the [ __ ] was the next one I was just
some sort of like coconut almond yummy
clusters or something was called Donna
that's how it was really this is like
this is the demographic come in let's
become fed [ __ ] and talk about how we
love each other
I don't want Thomas I get the underwear
and I thought and get back to the hotel
room and I realized am I looking down
and everybody in t.j.maxx
I forgot to get socks so I had to go
back to the gay store you know and you
know I come walking into the store and
the same dudes behind the counter and I
was just like dude you got I you sell
socks here you know because all I had
was white socks I was going to sit down
at church and they were going to come up
near like ankles like nike socks I was
gonna wear like [ __ ] wingtips I
wasn't gonna do that so they actually
had regular socks so that's what I
learned at the gay store they just had
regular nike socks but for some reason
the tag on them took a picture of it I
got to send this I went you know what
I'm going to tweet this up whatever the
tag on the socks just said [ __ ] please
that's just some I guess woman or maybe
a guy in drag with his face all twisted
up I got on [ __ ] police socks by Nike
you know and they failed normal these
are made for gay feet but for some
reason they seem to fit mine just just
fine I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about I mentioned earlier that I
hadn't been meditating and it came to a
head so to speak and everyone I was
bitching about updating my [ __ ] phone
and then trying to update my laptop and
there's no one to call and I'm typing in
the right passwords in the to are not in
sync and I don't know how to do it I
finally had a meltdown and my laptop was
closed and I took my phone and I just
[ __ ] slammed it down like corner first
onto my laptop you know somewhere
between a jab and an overhand right but
it was a stabbing motion and I don't
know what then I [ __ ] open my laptop
in the screen was broken so my question
I have for you guys is not doing anger
management I know I do
question is can people just fix a
[ __ ] screen you could do that it's
not the harddrive
there's no water get they just take that
out it's like I got a broken windshield
on my laptop can they can they do that
I'm gonna find out I'm gonna find out
because once again I didn't backup
anything there and I was just really
thinking like I didn't back anything up
and I didn't back anything up my phone
when I dropped it in the toilet but do I
miss any of that data data whatever how
the [ __ ] you say it and the reality is I
don't mean most of my pictures is taking
pictures of [ __ ] that I hate you know
people's dirty feet and [ __ ]
heartfelt photos and gay socks that say
[ __ ] please I mean do I do I really
need to save these somewhere I just love
the idea that these exist somewhere in a
cloud and this these [ __ ] people
trying to figure out with the [ __ ] that
I take a picture of like what can they
sell me next
KK socks coconut clusters I would thank
you from the bottom of my heart but for
you my heart has no problem okay this is
a fat game male with a sugar addiction
and a foot fetish um anyway so I got to
read oh by the way my daughter laughed
for the first time yesterday twice and I
was on the road and I didn't get to see
I didn't get to hear it but I'm hanging
out with her all all day today other
than the benefit I have to do tonight
and I'm really like psyched like I came
home and course dropped everything and
picked her up and she just smiled for
like three minutes straight which was
amazing and I could tell she was getting
sleepy and I can read her body language
she was on the floor and she started
doing this thing like she's trying to
sit up and my god she wants to get up
and I just put her on my lap and we were
watching these people in Maine we
building cabins or some [ __ ] and I felt
her start to slump slump to the right I
knew that she was falling asleep and she
was asleep which I was like this is a
perfect time to do the podcast but it
felt so awesome her just lay in there
that I stayed there for like another 20
minutes and I'm kind of breaking down
parenting into just like sections
I know like I was like I got 18 years
with her before she goes off to college
God willing so how many months is that I
just did three of them and then the
other big countdown is the first three
years so the first three years all I
have to do is just fill her up with love
support and when I do lose my temper
because I'm going to I'm going to
apologize to her and ask her to help me
work on it so she's not like necessarily
afraid you know I just I got to kill
this this aspect of my family tree
because everything else is pretty you
know acceptable but I don't want to be
the guy stabbing his [ __ ] laptop with
his phone freaking his kid out why do
you know who wants to be that person and
you're laying on your deathbed one day
they come walking in you know peeking in
still nervous to be around you spec yes
Aria sorry
damn I woke up we're both back in 1832 I
don't want to have that so yeah I'm
hanging out with her all day today
reading books and the whole thing so
I've also decided that guy right so I
still got to do my two weekends a month
so those would be like six days I won't
see her but I'll actually see her more
than if I had like a nine-to-five
because then I can come home and just
totally focus on her you know for the
next 10 days before I go out on the road
so you know and every person that's a
parent they all say it goes by so fast
it goes by so fast so I just keep
thinking that every [ __ ] time every
day so hopefully hopefully you know
hopefully I don't [ __ ] this up but I'm
not gonna lie to you I know I'm a mess
so I'm definitely uh you know jury's out
any people walk home a great dad I'm a
great dad shut the [ __ ] up that's not
for you to say somebody said that to you
you [ __ ] um you know who's awesome you
awesome man you know why because I said
so
alright audible okay here we go I'll get
some reads here this is the advertising
audible lue audible okay Lewis blacks
new book the great Louis black Louis
black the rant is
do is the new original comedy series
from audible channels I thought it was a
book they said it was a book Lewis flex
in the book you can hear the latest
episode for free right now at
audible.com slash Lewis Black now who
the [ __ ] wouldn't want to hear a book
written but uh
ret written and read by Lewis Black I'm
doing this this show is written by the
fans you can't you can rant about
everything from politics to
relationships to anything that's driving
you mad by submitting your rant to Lewis
Black right now and listening to the
rent is due for free at audible.com/asap
for anyone that doesn't know Lewis Black
he's a comedy hero a regular on The
Daily Show
he's got stand-up specials on HBO and
Comedy Central he's the voice of anger
and inside out and he's got over a
million fans connecting every day on
social media I remember the first time I
saw Lewis Black I saw him at the Comedy
Cellar right before he blew up he was
about my age maybe a little young about
45 46 and it was one of those [ __ ]
hot brutally hot summer days in LA and
he came in still wearing his sport coat
and all that and he was just like
miserable okay he already walks around
with a certain level of agitation which
I could totally relate to his remember I
said I walk around at a six so going up
to ten isn't that quick of a ride so
Lewis came in and there was like nobody
in the [ __ ] club it was like the mid
90s like 95 96 and comedy was still
dealing with the 80s hangover still
waiting to make another comeback and so
he goes in there in front of like three
[ __ ] people out on three tables of
people whatever and I had never seen him
and he got in there and he was legit
upset about how [ __ ] hot it was
outside and then you combined that with
his material in his stage persona and he
got that finger going and it was like
I'll never forget that I was [ __ ]
dying disc
I was in front of like 11 people
murdering like he was at Carnegie Hall
and that was just one of those great
just moved in New York and it was just
one of those great oh my god who the
[ __ ] is this guy how have I never seen
this guy how doesn't everybody know who
this guy is and within like I was like
95 96 and I want to say he hit around
like 99 what was quick
within like by 1999 I think he went out
on a road and he did that that classic
comedy tour lineup it was him Mitch
Hedberg and Dave Attell can you believe
that that was a [ __ ] tour hey we're
going to go out and go see comedy
tonight oh yeah whoo you seen I don't
know this guy Lewis Black this
up-and-coming guy Mitch Hedberg I'm
trying to think of Dave Attell how to
show you and something he had insomniac
maybe Mitch had his half-hour out but um
I didn't even get to see that [ __ ]
tour because I was too busy slugging it
out my [ __ ] Helms I would have loved
to have seen that
so anyways I'm sitting here babbling
supposed to be greeting uh advertise I'm
telling stories i frame bridge everybody
so weird I just shot one day on a movie
and framing him Framingham Massachusetts
out there on [ __ ] off of Route nine I
believe I used to do the Nixon
Framingham out there a long time ago
oh but 20 years way to go all right
frame bridge everybody give your
personal experience using frame bridge
calm if applicable I've never used it it
sounds like a great idea but I stab my
[ __ ] laptop in the face stabbed it in
the face I always have to say in the
face you know what that's from that's
from the great performance given by that
cop in the bathroom in Reservoir Dogs
the way he the rhythm of the way he
speaks is so like perfect cop I said
buddy I am gonna shoot you in the face
you don't put your [ __ ] hands in a
dashboard
that's one of those movies when you've
seen it that many times like all the
usual good lines that everybody quotes
out of the [ __ ] blue you know I'm
trying to be a [ __ ] professional you
know it's got Big Chill [ __ ] all
those ones that everybody knows yeah
yeah yeah ban ban ban ban ban look at
they haven't done what I told them not
to go everybody knows those lines but
then once you want once you get up to
like you know three four hundred
viewings of it which you really can do
in the summer if you [ __ ] put your
mind to it and you have no social life
like me yeah that's when you start going
who the [ __ ] is this guy playing this
cop the way he's killing this monologue
I don't know I don't know why it just
reminded me of this comedian Danny live
from Philly and I remember when he was
he was doing this white guy Denny's a
black dude so he's doing this white guy
and the way he was doing the cadence in
the wake the way the guy was talking was
you know that was like sort of at the
height of the fallout of the hacky white
guy right now Jay like I'll do my taxes
like that [ __ ] thing but he was
actually legitimately doing a white guy
like an impression that I couldn't even
[ __ ] do but I could see the dude that
he was doing those those are the nerd
things that I like when I'm watching
[ __ ] but anyways frame bridge no no
experience but the dota frame bridge
calm choose your frame or let their
designers help you choose upload your
photo from your computer or directly
from Instagram preview your photo online
in the frame you choose exclamation
point this is where it's getting
exciting everybody can upload your photo
or art don't stab your laptop with your
smartphone no worries you can mail it
you can mail it in for free it's
affordable this is this is so that part
is totally for [ __ ] old people like
me you can call up the Pony Express you
can do it that way the expert team at
frame bridge will custom frame your item
in days not weeks or months and deliver
your finished piece directly to your
door ready to hang
frame bridge offers a happiness
guarantee their team I hate when they do
[ __ ] like that are you happy we're just
doing a follow-up call were you 100%
satisfied I don't think I've ever been
100% satisfied about anything well that
kind of goes against our team spirit
Awards all right Elijah I'm 100%
satisfied with my [ __ ] photo of you
no impulse items at t.j.maxx their team
gives each item personal care and
attention because meeting your
expectation is as important as meeting
their own yes somebody's cracking the
whip over there
don't get stuck searching for a
last-minute gift order for now for
mother's day delivery
go to Frank that's a great idea picture
you and your mom you know she's going to
love that this is cheapest [ __ ] it's
perfect for all you tightwads that love
your mom but don't think she's good
enough to spend money this is what you
do go to frame bridge calm and use promo
code burr be URR you'll save an
additional 15% off your first order just
go to frame bridge calm promo code per
frame bridge calm promo code bar all
right here we go
how many more of these [ __ ] two two
more of these things all right Oh blue
apron everybody speaking and getting rid
of your man tits this is a good way to
do it in ladies you'll be able to keep
your tits and get rid of UCB which is
right below you know what it means
between Yahoo and your titties the old
Seabee there um sorry blue apron
everybody see remember that [ __ ]
movie that was just up on the CB was
just above [ __ ] truckers Kris
Kristofferson was was in it and Ernest
Borgnine was was the state trooper up
there in the helicopter convoy and I
remember that they were trying to get
this [ __ ] convoy of trucks to just
stop driving it was like vanishing point
with like 70 72,000 [ __ ] 18-wheelers
they just were they weren't stopping for
nothing man they were just out there and
you're just gonna keep all driving
so these cops were trying to stop them
and for some reason couldn't so now
Ernest Borgnine you know sort of the
go-between between truckers and cops
like he understands them so there's some
[ __ ] up in the elevator
God hey you [ __ ] truckers this is
this is the police
we're up here at a helicopter we really
don't have a gun turn or anything but
we're watching you so you better be
nervous you know he's trying to make
threats up there in this [ __ ]
helicopter so Ernest Borgnine it just
shakes his head he goes a tank and
listen to that and he grabs the CB goes
these truckers he goes they got a
language all their own and then he goes
to talk to them down there and he goes
this is the bear in the air don't forget
I delivered that line I even [ __ ] up
this is the bear in the air like Smokey
the Bear you know smokey the compound I
have to break it down to you know that's
one of the things that I can't [ __ ]
stand
I hate when obvious slang people feel
that they have to break it down to you
you know what I mean
I mean one time I saw this one-man show
and the guy goes we were going into
Maddy Haddie he goes that's Manhattan
for all you white people I want to be
like oh thank you I couldn't figure that
without it was so it was so quick and
clever I mean you almost say in
Manhattan and of course they got a laugh
white people they don't understand
things all right let's get what am i
technically in the middle of re here
alright blue apron yeah this is about
food and aprons ok blue aprons mission
is to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everyone
alright it's about time up until the
button told blue apron only the upper 1%
we're allowed to have food prepared for
them well the rest of us are [ __ ] non
on Bush's because blue apron ships the
exact amount of each ingredient required
for the recipe
you better not [ __ ] spill anything no
they are reducing food waste because
it's the exact amount you bought
bastards you're going to be like a
crackhead crawled around a motel [ __ ]
floor looking for a rock
did the basil go under the bed cooking
together build strong family bonds Jr
it's time to put in the sugar
research shows research research shows
that blue apron families cook nearly
three times more often those who spend a
lot at restaurants or at high-end
grocery stores can now spend under $10
per person for a delicious meal each
meal too weird word just really good
meal you guys want to have a meal a meal
what a meal each meal comes with a
step-by-step easy-to-follow recipe card
and pre-portioned ingredients and can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less blue
aprons freshness guarantee promises that
every ingredient in your delivery
arrives ready to cook or they'll make it
right check out this week's menu and get
your first three meals for free with
free shipping by going to blue apron com
slash bur you'll love how good it feels
and taste to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
away that's blue apron calm / / blue
apron at Santa Rita cook I love that
blue apron a better way to cook this is
so many different ways you can do that
language blue apron up better way to
cook right like [ __ ] Ving Rhames we
have the leeks how great is that [ __ ]
advertising campaign I've never had a
desire to eat there ever it's like I
don't want fast food roast beef does
anything [ __ ] die quicker than
[ __ ] roast beef I mean I know it's
dead already
you know rotting flesh is all you
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] vegetarians talk
about like your plants not dead already
- there's such dopes they really are all
of them every single one of them I put
them all in one group because that's
what I do because I don't take the time
to get to know people okay and right now
it's I think this country needs a little
more of that don't you alright see so
everyone attention comedy nerds come to
a magical place called seaso where new
stand-up comedy specials debut every
month this month they have big Jay
oakerson
with what's your [ __ ] deal a stand-up
series featuring nothing but crowd work
that's funny man from big J and dozens
of headlining comics that's a [ __ ]
great name for a show what's your
[ __ ] deal it just picks her big J
sitting there and it's on the stool just
look around your [ __ ] deal what do
you do
it's filling you up with C so you get
unlimited access to C so original series
disease next day late night hilarious
stand-up specials binge worthy classics
including forty two seasons of Saturday
Night Live that's crazy
everyone you want to watch the entire
Monty Python catalogue the it crowd and
more sign up now to catch brand-new
stand-up specials from the great Nick
DiPaolo from the incredible Joey sorry I
try to do it like Michael buffer a boost
buffer actually trying to boost buffer
and the new season of big Jay oakerson
is what's your [ __ ] deal or watch
your favorite sets from comedians like
Fahim Anwar pronounced Fahim aren't
Anwar dude you know what does everybody
have to start on big Jay oakerson show
do you have to say what's your [ __ ]
deal you got to say I mean it's almost
like a game show right
all of it higher you know this there's
certain things that you have to say I
can't think of a catchphrase from a game
show anyways hey Bill the show's already
a hit it's in its second season they
don't need you [ __ ] retooling it it's
like some ghost producer fair enough
all right access see so content from
anywhere at any time using iOS Android
Roku Apple TV Amazon fire Amazon fire TV
that sounds like a bad [ __ ] I don't
know vodka or cologne or some [ __ ]
windows on or Xbox one ready for the
punt Xbox one sorry ready for the punch
line I thought one ready was the name of
one of those things ready for the punch
line yes bill we are seaso is just 399
per month no joke 399 per month for all
the comedy you want Anytime Anywhere
ad free ad free
you listen to an ad right now how
annoying is this you're free of this
just go to see SOCOM s EES Oh calm
Sierra echo echo Sierra Oscar calm right
now to sign up for one month for free
with promo code burr at checkout debt C
SOCOM spelled SE e s o comm promote
promo code burr C SOCOM promo Kroeber
alright not to nitpick but I would have
spelt it SE e soo so when you spell it
out you know - e - s is two E's two O's
C so C so alright let's plow ahead here
uh alright okay oh Jesus Boston sports
let's talk Boston sports dot data
jesus what a couple of [ __ ] games
those were all right let's start which
the Boston Bruins we've lost three games
straight to the Ottawa
[Music]
I missed the LA I missed yesterday
night's game because I was at the
memorial service but I definitely
watched Game two in Game three and
although we had a fury it's got back in
Game three it was not enough I was
actually in the north end in the cigar
bar smoking a stogie hoping it was going
to be a good thing
what a [ __ ] that was a great goal
going over time it'll give and go got to
admit and I don't know I don't know they
just been out playing us and they they
deserve it now granted it was a [ __ ]
call but there's going to be [ __ ] calls
it's just going to happen but you know I
don't know [ __ ] call an oh [ __ ] call
we've lost three games in a row so I
mean get on you can only look in the
mirror so we'll see what happens the
excitement of the Bruins making the
playoffs is quickly subsiding here I
would like to see them win a series and
now there they get their [ __ ] backs
up against the wall so we'll see we'll
see well say when game 5 comes up I
imagine tomorrow alright and then the
Celtics
oh Jesus Celtics have been completely
exposed I know that that's probably been
said a thousand times you know it's
funny is when I first got back into the
NBA which I got back into it because
Paul virzi was coming out here and he
loves the NBA and he was staying with me
him and his lovely wife staying with me
and my lovely wife for like four or five
days and I'm a hell of a host oh what a
host would host right so I'm just like I
well you know I'm first he's coming to
town I got to get some Johnny blue I got
to get the NBA package so he can watch
his Nixon I just got into the Celtics so
I've been watching him since December of
2015 and my first thought when I was
watching him I was like where are we
going to go with this game plan we have
this super star point guard we live and
die by the three and we don't get any
[ __ ] rebounds like I don't understand
how you can win anything playing
basketball like that but then here's
what happened they did and they just
kept winning and everybody else it just
became socially acceptable on the hard
court to [ __ ] run down the court with
the ball three people from the other
team onto the net nobody on your team or
maybe one guy it was totally acceptable
to say I'm not waiting for my other
teammates and I'm just going to launch a
[ __ ] three you know and we're up by
one with like [ __ ] eight minutes to
go like what are you doing
but that just you know the same way
after Jordan people just like well I
guess we don't need to feed it to a big
man do we even need a big man read it
you know what I was like all right I
guess this is the new game so we end up
not only doing great this year
once we added al horford yeah we [ __ ]
got the number one seat and at that
point I completely forgot about my
initial reaction to the way that they
were playing and I was like all right I
guess yeah the number one see we get an
eight-seat alright and after the first
two games it's like you know it seems
like the opposite seems like they're the
number one seed and we're the eight seed
and I kind of knew we were in trouble
uh I guess well when Charles Barkley
just basically broke our team down after
the first half of the first game going
yeah you just basically you double-team
Isiah try to make him beat the double
and then if these guys don't hit their
threes you know they're not getting any
[ __ ] I don't know what the hell he said
but it's just like alright this guy's
already figures out basically what I'm
saying is I think this is the first real
test for Brad Stevens this next game
where he has to make a drastic
adjustment with the players that he has
because they figured us out before the
opening tip-off and that has led to two
losses and we have not been able to make
any adjustment and what's fascinating
about the Bulls is even though that
they're an eighth seed they got Rondo
and they got Dwyane Wade and Rondo has
got a ring and I think Dwyane Wade he's
got what three rings four rings
he won one with Shaq and then two with
LeBron three with LeBron I can't
remember I'm not a big NBA guy he's got
at least three weeks so there's four
rings right there those guys I've been
through it numerous times so they're not
afraid of the the ebbs and flows of the
game they're not afraid of playing on
the road they're just totally chill and
I think that affects the rest of the
team and then you got Butler and Lopez
who have just [ __ ] animals just
hitting you know 12-foot jump shots 15
footers while getting all these rebounds
and then that [ __ ] white dude from
Europe Vlade Divac jr. D Bob jr. he's
[ __ ] started hitting threes and you
know we're getting our asses kicked so
I'll see what happens and you know but
uh Jesus Christ I mean we were down
three two one and hockey went down
Oh to going out to Chicago so I'm hoping
I'm hoping yes Jesus so we don't get
[ __ ] swept I mean I don't know brutal
brutal brutal but you know what he can
do it and Agee it's just a [ __ ] game
I realized that if the first one when
I'm watching you know Isiah Thomas
crying about losing his sister was
really a brutal week for that type of
[ __ ] huh
and Aaron Hernandez hung himself man I
was [ __ ] brutal the whole thing was
brutal and then all those [ __ ] jokes
that people were making like oh yeah he
got hung up he's got an upper body
injury to the [ __ ] neck oh well this
dumb [ __ ]
that that [ __ ] to me is always weird
where you going to sell that guy's a
murderer he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and and then everybody acts like a
[ __ ] animal when he kills himself of
course there's people out there that
don't think you know something else
happened it's like alright you got just
got acquitted on those other two murders
and then you had a good chance for an
appeal you know you had some hope but I
don't know who the [ __ ] knows I don't
know what the [ __ ] happened I don't
necessarily agree with that or disagree
I have no [ __ ] idea but I do know was
I think you've any sort of a [ __ ]
human being the whole thing was just sad
it's just like you know is every just
all these lives just [ __ ] thrown away
over nothing
granted you know obviously he pulled the
[ __ ] trigger and everything like that
but still I don't take any sort of I
don't know I just I didn't get that it
was just like it was just yeah it's what
I was think he's just from front to back
you just wish it didn't happen in Tabriz
like hey here's my [ __ ] obvious joke
so anyway out god am I really gonna be
talking about [ __ ] him killing
himself is that how I'm going to end
this podcast how long has this punk ass
been 43 minutes well you know what I
mean overtime alright let's end up on
something positive tonight of course I'm
working tonight
and this [ __ ] band that I've been
wanting to see cuz they're drummers
amazing I don't have his name in front
of me I should have it but I don't span
called Russian Circles is playing he's
playing at the for [ __ ] sakes what's the
name of the [ __ ] thing every goddamn
theater because of the P out here hey I
gotta hit pause I got to make sure I
have this information holding Englund
the Palladium [ __ ] to take a paramount
the pompadour the [ __ ] Palladium
actually that's where richard pryor
taped live on the Sunset Strip so I was
introduced to this band they played this
song Harper Lewis live and their drummer
absolutely [ __ ] blew me away with his
just how solid his his beats were and
then his use of dynamics it's just on a
whole other [ __ ] level which I really
think is a lost art but they're playing
tonight since 6:30 p.m. and I wish I
could go but I got a [ __ ] goddamn
benefit so I can't make it but I'll post
that clip of the band playing that song
Opelousas it's the live version and just
the way you know it just starts off with
the drumbeat that he's playing and he's
playing it you know it gradually builds
in intensity gets louder and louder and
then then when they go into that oh it's
an instrumental band I don't know how to
say versus chorus I don't know what the
[ __ ] they're doing but just absolutely
blew me away
you got nothing to do tonight you want
to see a killer band go down get a
couple of tickets to that I guarantee
you you have a great time all right that
is the podcast arm I guess because it's
4/20 like weed man I guess Andrews going
to be giving you guys some extra clips
it's going to be a little bit longer and
and that is it and it was an honor to be
a Charlie Murphy's memorial service it
was an honor to know that guy and I want
to thank everybody who spoke that night
last night the way that they sent that
guy off it was just like it was it just
was a level of greatness in the
performances that I saw from the
comedian's that went up and spoke and
Charlie was one of the greats you know
and it was just it was such a perfect
send-off and I'm really glad that I was
able to be there and witness it all
right so that's it I'll you [ __ ]
[ __ ] have a great weekend and enjoy
this music and some some clips from a
podcast recorded in a Monday or a
Thursday gone by